so I grew up in Northeastern Ohio I was
always the young rambunctious one being
the youngest of six kids but I was the
adventurous one too so I'm one that
moved away from home
as soon as I turned 18 and my young
adult life we did a lot of canoeing and
kayaking and snowboarding and skiing and
fly fishing the outdoors actually means
a lot to me and I think there's always
this achievement and relaxation you have
when you're on the top of a mountain
looking out on that Friday was Friday
March 13th 1998 I was 26 years old I was
out snowboarding with a bunch of friends
and it just happened to be a full moon
that evening if you ever ski at night
during a full moon that the trails are
beautiful they just glow everybody made
it down to the bottom of the mountain
except for me on the way down I hit a
patch of ice and went down a 40-foot
embankment and ended up with a spinal
cord injury and from that point I became
a quadriplegic
and when that happens your life just
stops and I had to build my life all
over again and pick up the pieces and
put them back together again so Jen how
did you get from that accident to where
you are now I mean what was that interim
like that journey was actually a quite
profound because when me when your
spinal cord injured what so many of us
do is we try to find a solution and when
I finally came to the realization that
I'm going to be paralyzed and I have
this thing called a spinal cord injury I
had two drivers one is that I wanted to
combat all these secondary conditions
these life-threatening secondary
conditions that happen to people with
spinal cord injuries like kidney failure
and osteoporosis and pressure sores that
can die from infections so I was driving
to be able to keep my body healthy but
also that its second driver was to keep
my body healthy so I'm ready for when
that cure comes for spinal cord injury
so that last image you saw of me and an
FES bike I started to use FES cycling
which is basically putting electrodes on
the surface of the skin allowing
somebody to pedal a stationary bicycle
and in the process I was appealing my
insurance company and researching for
that appeal and I came across the
Cleveland FES Center and hunters
research team and from there they said
well here's the research and we're also
doing these clinical trials as well are
you interested and from there i joined
on and decided to be one of the test
pilots let's see it let's bring out the
walker so hunter actually showed that
the technology side but let me explain
to you how it really works so
so implant that's almost two main
components of the system
there's the implanted components and the
external components inside my body are
these electrodes that are implanted
either deep into the muscle tissue or
with nerves and those those electrodes
are implanted and then they're tunneled
through the fatty tissue into the
abdomen where I have two receivers that
look like that the image that you have
right there but it's much like a
pacemaker so I have two of those
implanted in my abdomen and all of that
is encapsulated inside the body so how I
use it is I have my external piece as
well I have a small coil that little
black coil that you see that I taped to
the skin that's just over the receiver
that coil connects to the external
control unit this thing that I'm wearing
around my waist so I'll be able to put
in a command into the to the box the box
sends a high level radio frequency to
the implant the implant decodes it sends
the messages to the electrodes and then
from that point forward it contracts
those muscles for for a viable function
so right now I have my back's on only
and see how much my posture is so
straight if I turn it off I can't sit up
straight my muscles are back being
paralyzed again so here before I stand I
actually turn on my back so that way I
have a good posture and when I put in a
command to stand the messages go to
those electrodes and allow me to stand
up out of my wheelchair independently
with no / no braces it's just my muscles
that are doing that movement so when I
turn off the system that signal stops -
those electrodes and I sit down and my
legs are back to being paralyzed just
like they were before how much control
of different kinds of movements does
this system give you well we have a
whole plethora of programs that are into
this box and that's the neat thing again
that with working with the researchers
as we as users went to them and said you
know if I could have a pressure-release
pattern so when I'm sitting on an
airline and
have to be able to relieve the presser
and my while I'm sitting how important
that is or I just want trunk control I
even have a pattern in here for a back
massage which is fantastic so how has
this changed your life the ability to
get vertical again well it's not only
allowed me to stay healthy and improve
my joints and to be able to combat all
of those secondary medical conditions
there's the everyday functional use like
standing up to to reach a shelf or do
daily chores like folding laundry and
doing dishes and things like that but
you're able to talk to somebody
eye-to-eye you're able to hug a loved
one I mean those types of things are
really important that we don't always
think about when they're doing the
technology to be able to participate in
a standing ovation or the seventh-inning
stretch of a baseball game or the thrill
of being able to compete at the
Paralympic Games and the one thing is
always near and dear to my heart is to
be able to stand and walk down the aisle
at our wedding
that was this radiator smile